hello grammarians today I want to start
talking about irregular verbs that is to
say verbs that are a little weird you
know we have this idea of a regular verb
that we can conjugate in all tenses and
it's just going to behave in a way that
we expect like for example the verb
talked right so if we if we take a
regular verb and we put it in the past
the present in the future this is what
it's going to look like
present tense talk future tense will
talk past tense
talked with that edie ending but there
are plenty of verbs in English as you
have no doubt discovered that don't
follow that basic rule present tense
this one form of the verb in the past
tense
the is the present with Edie tacked on
to it and then the future with will
tacked on to the front and there are
plenty of words in English as you have
no doubt discovered that don't behave
that way at all so let's let's take
another it let's take in a regular word
like run present tense run future tense
will run past tense RAM Oh weird
SuperDuper weird now there are a lot of
irregular verbs in English but you're
listening to someone with a grammar book
the size of a car so I think between the
two of us we can figure this out
together but for now let's just focus on
four verbs to be to have to do and to
say so let's take these verbs and make
them work for a bunch of different
people in different times so in the
first person when we're talking about
ourselves what I'm talking about myself
in the present I would say I am I have I
do I say if we're talking about someone
else in the present in the singular we
would say she is she has she does
and she says so the third person
singular is different in the way that
these words are pronounced so am because
this entirely different word is have
doesn't become halves it's has and do
doesn't become dues it becomes does we
actually change the the vowel sound here
just like say doesn't become says-- we
don't say she says in standard American
English we say she says in the present
tense we are we have we do we say and in
the past tense in the first person these
four verbs form the following I was I
had I did and I said and in the plural
past it was we were we had we did and we
said these four verbs are some of the
strangest ones in English but they're
the most important in another video I'm
going to go through some broad rules
that govern the rest of the irregular
verbs in English you can learn anything
Dave it out